we're going to solve this we resolved
this between non intricity so I like to
write back I like to make a point of
writing the domain restriction every
time because it is a common error
persistent just ignored of invitation
because it is certain often this that
they just sort of get into autopilot but
it's a typically extension thing to do
to throw you a curveball why does the
domain move on if they're 0 to 60
they'll make a minus 180 to 180 so right
now and then you get the habit of in
with the normal one you're conscious of
it right so you know look at this I know
the doubling of the resulting interviews
because this is only woman you will be
fairly happy with the main results if
this is the two I'll come back to that
so but now this is what I've done I'm
going to give this this trig function
over here to talk of disabling this
mystery talking with you BB will not
really do that so I've got three what my
hostages if we don't there is the
gallery called where the minus sign
again are not equal to looks like that
plus sign there then it would run you
within the tire and this in improving is
now literally doubling or anymore I read
all of the trick boxes are in the same
angle theta
I'll treat it on but I'm still moving
stuff because I want more than what kind
of tree functions and what can I do
head blow-up doll I'm definitely okay I
do could you make it like this I had an
idea yes as we can now you see always
wake up before you River said I'll
square it right when you see things that
I already squared that's kind of should
be a flashing lights see where it
centered the practical areas identities
what connects the squares together so I
only ever remember actually that I
cannot remember you know I mean I know
either you can or you remember if you
like isn't that one I'm not sure right
and you've got to come back to something
you can guarantee to use this here I
need to make a substitution that a way
to get rid of all these back right here
is exercise right the squares are easy
to work with this guy though because
they put another one group that's a bad
thing on the caramel so I'm going to say
that cold squared is 1 minus sine
squared so now you make the solution so
what what
okay Toyota - this is what - two times
with five x squared - 3 - 6 sine squared
plus 500 you let me do that one wait for
you and your career
exactly I'm going to suggest that we
subtract 1 from both sides which means
that I can collect like terms there and
then treat this as a quadratic function
set in platinum I thought maybe it'd be
a member for Huntington just for
convenience sake I'm going to light
everything through by negative 1
okay can you try that you can be eluted
yeah living agreeable and agree it will
be negative for free so how do I do if
you want to go straight in fact I don't
do to break this into two then pair up
or live singing six times when we love
vibrators false idea and then yeah okay
okay do you see that were you like learn
for sure okay she's one of those dudes
I'm looking for the number that lock the
Parana by one person in each one is a
traditional I make that so beta 4 is 3
so I'm going to break apart this guy
into negative 4 and 3 you're my master
can just be like change the sign Gosha
no today is five at that point I'm going
to avoid doing that if I can deal with
this because it's just 13 you do stuff
if you're going to work but in fact it's
okay so over the this parent here I can
take a factor of truce idea which
conveniently leave you with in 370 of
money - all right plus one three cent
here others too right so now I
definitely not my petrol engine Julie
times need a my plus one three
I knew it
don't have any ties in 29 yeah it's
tight either one which is why I've
started to as a student I never used to
write it down and then I start teaching
but oh that's really handy because it
helps you to avoid missing out do you
want to continue or do you reckon you've
gone from there which other than keep on
okay sure
so pretty okay let's go from there would
you would you like squid to graduate in
computing
I'm one side the employer I needed you
sir
yeah that's right so this thing over
here the left is in fact right to
products if you have something x equals
zero if water if it has to be you and if
one of these zero you don't care what
the other legal to because here it has
well here so therefore are from this
part here I have two sons the plus 1
equal to 0 that's true I don't care what
this is I'll get a solution in exactly
the same way if this is equal to 0 and I
don't kill that one is this will get me
in solution so I've got sine theta equal
despair we want on to can you do this in
your head or Jeeva will this help on a
much more affordable
we couldn't it is essential
what's the base angle huh good done it
like if you look at that you've gotta
keep those secrets like oh this is going
to be we call this floozy it's like what
I'm driving I can't be worrying about
weight top body tremors do you really
get to teriyaki that's just going to
come naturally so that I can work
traffic no reach as they compete with
that see you lose this ability that we
rely on that right which is why I was
pushing when you can practice to be a
better four quadrants the basic we stay
in the fourth quadrant were 3185 is the
fourth quadrant it's increasingly - so
you've dealt with that done busting you
come here sciency is not going to be
exact values this is two three so you
need to reach for your calculator again
you've got the quadrants there so which
one it's generally substitute okay so
the calculator we hand you the first one
which is what you want waiting will for
it disagree let's just for engineers to
go to Panama approximately and then to
get the second culture table you've got
to go children a takeaway which is our
country and thirteen
yes my passengers time change the houses
you're testing a bit of funny murder
therefore I think it's important even
though I've written theory everything I
do I think it's important that at the
end I conclude by click all the bits
together so I'll take T equals 20 to 40
to 130 age 210 or well so it before
you're saying how are you don't think
you can zero an event about the unwanted
Irwin so the idea is even see a theory
would turn to 10 then decided oh within
your heart then just identify equal zero
so this is zero this will not be 0
it must put insurance integrate
interview this will not be zero maybe
something else but I don't care up to
something else is computed that will
still be B 0 will still be a solution so
what I read it I think solve this is
isolation to this one and I can solve
this in isolation to this one and then
I'm your body ready to go